these forests in Romania Stran Sylvania
region are the hunting grounds of
gamekeepers attila cheeky and Shandor
Ference this is the home of europe's
largest predator the brown bear
the brown bears natural habitat is
remote from human settlements but the
Bears population keeps growing currently
there are more than 6,000 here the
hunters say this is a problem they're
finding more and more bear tracks
outside of the forests the population is
simply too large too many are living
here so they're spreading even into the
villages and the people living in the
surrounding farms suffer the
consequences when seeking a meal a
Romanian brown bear isn't exactly choosy
especially if it's hungry a few weeks
ago a bear killed livestock belonging to
farmer fed and spiro first he tried to
come through the window here you can see
the marks from his claws that didn't
work so he destroyed the door and
attacked my cows menB but humans share
responsibility for the rising attacks
many villages border the forest and
villagers often dump their garbage at
the edge of their settlement bears are
omnivorous and see the trash as a bite
to eat just a few meters in front of our
camera a bear goes for the garbage
containers
lasya chuckles empirically they're
dangerous for humans don't forget they
are wild animals and unpredictable you
can never know how they react at any
given moment - not to me no advocate to
control the danger the community has
assigned Ference image to regularly
check the garbage containers many of
which are now kept in cages like these
but Fannin says that doesn't always stop
the Bears here one has even torn away
the concrete foundation to get at the
loot this amateur video from - SHhhh nod
shows how a bear can react when his meal
is disturbed a young bear charges after
local residents who flee in panic this
time all ended well but bears are
increasingly injuring people and there
have even been deaths Romania's game
keepers say the threat will increase up
to now a hundred bears could be hunted
and killed each year to regulate the
population but the government has now
banned bear hunting the effect is that
bears lose their fear of humans because
they're no longer hunted that can have
bad consequences many hunters are angry
at this man Leonardo baretsky he's an
animal rights activist and bear expert
who helped get the ban passed he says
all the talk about dangerous bears is
just fear-mongering there are very very
balanced animals for many points of view
and this is proof that in many areas in
Romania where the Bears occur in the
cities there's time to garbage dumpster
they're really so rare those incidents
where bears attack people I think it's
much bigger threat the car who is
running at 1 meter from us every day
this friend of the Bears thinks the
hunters are only upset about losing
business
people from all over the world want to
hunt bears and the Romanian hunting
associations charged three to eight
thousand euros for the coveted trophies
those bears are selected by hunters
which are big bears and this logical
because these individuals bring the
money but even the little bear in
Leonardo's care isn't tame as he
experiences a few seconds later
gamekeeper Attila cheeky takes us where
camera teams haven't been welcomed
before the hunting stand as we drive
there he says the gamekeepers need the
hunting feeds because the romanian state
provides too little funding for their
work
we continue to the hunting lodge on foot
here
he and Shandor Ferentz often lay in wait
for days with their wealthy clients who
want to take home a bearskin and then
suddenly it's here he's eight or nine
years old a large male the bear is
focused on this heap of garden waste its
bait to attract them shooting a bear
this size used to bring the gamekeepers
7,000 euros
it's a huge loss for us that these
predators can no longer be hunted that
costs us the important revenues we
urgently need for our territory many of
us are afraid we'll go broke then
another bear trots on to the clearing a
female hunters say the ban only
increases the number of poachers
shooting Europe's most powerful
predators
[Music]